kultur wo man drin erzählt zugang zu der
innerlichkeit zu sensibilität zu gefühl
mein großvater im august das gefühlt hat
[Musik]
das ist die vierte staffel von fleisch
und bossard dem format wo wir über
philosophische alltagssorgen bankett kam
mit dem fund mehrerer babbel das habe
das riesig über die vielen kommentare
nur über hans die letzten staffeln und
freude dass damit alle gespräche und
diskutieren und mein name ist heute
sprach das thema wo braucht haben es bei
euch interessiert
hochsensibilität wie sensibel schwierig
sein
kollege würde
ich finde es ist tagesformabhängig und
dann muss man doch was ist sensibel aber
ich habe zwei töchter
sexy und 3 und die ältere jahren das
gefühl ist sehr sensibel also es geht ja
es gibt vieles was ich ihre stromkosten
an
zusätzliches vertreten und sicher wieder
papa und muss alle aktien platzieren und
das ist für mich immer so schön kann man
immer das machen die geschichte ist eben
von der prinzessin auf der erbse und mit
den verschiedenen matratzen sind etwas
über land leute und unteren
bahnabschnitt spürt immer noch besser
sein dass kinder umgebracht und rettete
darf um sensible und das klinikteam ihre
tochter
die familie fast das oft mit einem buch
aufs wc zu lassen
und mit einem stück das ich bin so
[Musik]
was wird persönliche strategie steht die
ganze tour sehen welche ist kann zu den
kopfhörer europahalle im ladung ist in
barkow soloprogramm
für viel aufsehen sensibel sind
hochsensibel sind die home office
trainerin sagt sie
wo wir zum beispiel mit hochsensiblen
privaten kontakte aus zu stehen mit den
diskutierten und stritten das freut mich
extrem hab schon mal strategien
entwickeln aber halt nur begrenzt viele
vor dem phänomen betroffen sind
erschließung sogenannter neuro
sensitivität ich hab jetzt wirklich wo
der chinese shao träger der bisherige
sondern besuchermassen besucht war es
einfach nur dass es wissenschaftlich
noch nicht wirklich kurzer vorstellung
an und kassierte
zugeschrieben
aber
ganz klar das ist nicht besonders ist
geschafft und das ist vielleicht weniger
sondern ein
beschleunigungsrennen hans killer
schneller aggressiver
wettbewerber und insofern stiegen sofort
wenn ich für die leistungsgesellschaft
wenn so und so viel zu sagen dass ich
mich schnell dass ich mit das können wir
auch die
willis oder luchs fischotter ladens wäre
es aber wenn man die geschichte geht es
schon um den 200 oma die krankheit oder
neue rastani also eine
schwäche wo man den erich klemm gerade
wenn das berner hat so etwas früher für
eine verpflichtung die hand der sogkraft
fällt das einfach alles zu merken
schnell ist die beschleunigung die
fehlende hilfe also klar weiß nicht ob
das zur klarheit ob es immer schon jetzt
einfach mehr entdeckt das muss man
ausklammern zu finden aber ist das der
richtige zug richtung stimmt die
diagnosen oder die frankreich ist es
nicht so dass das konzept vertrauen
könnten so die autoren ihr wertfrei das
schwere das stück wie dem auswärtige und
wenn man gesellschaft hat wo sehr stark
setzt aus brasilien auf starke noch zum
sensiblen tiere unverbindlich als auch
landrat lieber wenn ich natürlich andere
schnell innere abwertung
ist doch ein schneller den temporären
ich habe den verdacht dass ist genau
umgekehrt also sieht auch das
28 27 und freude psychoanalyse sozusagen
die kultur wo man drin als fehlende
zugang zur innerlichkeit zur
sensibilität zu gefühl mein großvater
immer das gefühl hat ich sage ich jetzt
mal
mit der rundtour mit dem anbau oder mit
der frau werde aber das findet so etwas
wie eine feministin jährige fotograf und
kulturstadt wenn man die klassische
rolle
er hat philosophie befasst sich sie 2004
mit emotionen
große emotionen
vernunft und das klappt das ist ein
trend ist heißt das noch
hochsensibilität oder hoch hyper oder so
besonders sowie hochbegabt das heißt es
ja sehr positiv kommentiert und es ist
ein es ist sozusagen selbst zu schäbig
wo blüht sogar erleichtert wenn sie
wüssten sie hängt das und schnittigen
aufwartet sondern sehr
positive werte zu tage früher zu sehen
das sind interessante
interessanten zuschauer das thema
gewünscht haben unterschrieben ohne die
lieder time es ist wohl die lead award
und wichtig sind aber auch sie findet
hinaus schauen dass ich negativ
konnotierte sensibel
aber nun so stark wie früher das war
durch sagen das gibt es neben neues
gegeben oder leistungskurs das abhängt
und so weiter aber die klar getrennt ist
hat aber und wird mit rum wie es zum
teil positiv konnotierte trafen sich
schon immer menschen wo die starke
sensibilität und dark knight hat und vom
system um ihn geht damit identifizieren
der
philosophische
hochsensibilität
klasse haben würde nicht doch sehr
ausgeprägt aber sie habe ich bin einfach
telefonieren sondern diesen terminen
machen und das vorbereiten und zu bieten
wann darüber dass auf und findet ja ich
glaube dass gott befehlen der diagnose
ist das so abb autismus oder bio heißt
und so weiter wenn du weißt du etwas
geht eine offizielle bezeichnung fotos
und zu bestätigen die schräg oder faul
ist das irgendwie und ich glaube das ist
das ist sehr wichtig aber würde das
finde ich dort dann interessant es gibt
die studie besagt dass menschen zur
hochsensibilität neige zum euro
sensitivität zum teil auch all dies
geschieht
und es geht sehr interessant die ihre
werke ausgehend vom handy film also vor
dem
hirnforschung oder blue brain project
etwas was man nicht machen bauen der
juso wo in spektrum ist und das brauhaus
buch geschrieben und er sagt dass man
einfach all dies muss aber immer falsch
geschrieben und es geht wirklich der
theorie betrachtet
und dann noch i got all dies muss heißt
nicht dass du auf die standspur dass du
eigentlich nicastro das nehm ich
gewartet und kontaktaufnahme menschen
sondern der kontakt in finsterer als so
intensiv
und darum seit er an das ganze große
verwandtschaft und offenbar in den
branchen die am 8 das finde ich
interessant finde zum beispiel seit es
geht keine solche berühmt es geht eine
falsche und gar nicht vorstellen das ist
natürlich richtig könnte genauso schön
und das wäre natürlich ideal oder das
wäre ideal
ja genau mit unendliche reise wird
sondern zuwider ist das natürlich der
idealzustand ich finde auch also das
individuum zu zudem fand ihm erlaubt die
in erwartung begrenzte ressourcen etwas
geld und nicht um ein nicht unendlich
vielen arbeitszimmer direkt für die
ganze belegschaft und dann muss
natürlich ganz europa ksze griff sag ich
jetzt mal muss ich aber für sehr
sensible und persönliche wachsartige
hier finden wo sie sich schützen und
abschieden losgeht miteinanders von uns
nicht funktioniert wenn wir die
idealtypische walter gedanken einfach
das ist glaube dass man ein sehr schöner
ist ihr gott es mir gott was jedes
einzelne sucht aber wir müssen die
stadträte was man als gesellschaft ja
wenn das berichtet wird ja oft da
sondern verbindet ich glaube allerdings
falsch also in generation diagnose zieht
diagnose snowflakes also die die
empfindliche generation der politik
correctness abfahrt liegt noch safe
spaces also rom wo man nicht irgendwie
hier beleidigt wird micro aggression und
ganz viel so begriff sind sie gar einige
jahre im unter und
meistens vor der gegnerischen seite wird
das zuzugeben oder das meer so
verweichlicht die hypersensiblen heutige
sind ich glaube das darf man ein wenig
für menschen oder also so wie nichts
jetzt klarer verstoß
hochsensibilität bis völlig anders aus
für seine aktuelle store für gleichheit
straka diskriminierung und die casa
subtil so dass andere eine sensorische
sensibilität sie also nach esslingen
bereits ganz feine antennen genau
antenne zwar sinnlichkeit vergrößert
oder lila oder grün oder einen auf der
eigenen zu der eigenen emotion und
anderen ist ein flug vor der
vergesslichkeit wo halt subtilen in den
gott vor verwendet also ich würde es
nicht weder für mensch und wird oft
gemacht ich finde es wichtig dass du
mich finden aber es gibt noch ein wenig
doch nochmals völker wir reden wir
eigentlich
als buch erschienen für des senders los
- den sieben wovon einen neuen
empfindlichkeit und genauigkeit es geht
so wollen es wird sind viel zu
empfindlich die ganze gesellschaft 10 10
zwischenstand endlichkeit disco sie
kommen und wie sie aussieht dass der
diskurs natürlich ist es auch tante
jahrhundert muss plötzlich ein konstrukt
roman
geschrieben
und kulturhistorikerin hat das buch
schäfer in ventimiglia anreiz und sie
stellt die these auf dass eigentlich die
briefe von hand vorläufig sie sehen für
die idee für die menschen zuerst einmal
besser und 7
und dennoch und die idee in der 3 alle
braucht gewisse
griffiges länder das buch zeitlichen
in serie mussten die politik will ich
glaube dass das
fundament und haben vor dem morales ist
es ist es mit viel sensibilität
fähigkeit können sich auch andere trieb
ersetzen oder und letztlich peter singer
gezeitigt die argumente die täglich das
man halt moral heißt dann bietet der
kreis gießen
genau dass man menschen mit anderer
hautfarbe mit anderer herkunft und
anderen geschlecht völlig irgendein tier
und so wieder versucht rittner ihre der
kreis vor den vorhang zu messen und
diskutieren in der kreis foto moral es
gibt beim richard rorty
der luft schweben oder eine these trat
oder saftigkeit ist eigentlich ein grund
erweitert die loyalität dass er gott
funk viel los und zeit nicht der
vernunft leid verstoßen richtige ist
wird vertrieb design zum handeln direkt
sondern nach yuma der tradition
und seit letztlich ist moral
eigentlichen bildung des herzens oder
also educación die mental mit dem
floberg das glaube ich ist total wichtig
also wie es nützte wittwer der
kategorische imperativ aus waren die
könnt und arbeitet aber nix ahnt dass
das ein mensch ist oder dass das die
ihre halle und der ungleichheit das
jetzt nicht ich habe natürlich einen
jäger gefühlt spricht dass sie irgendwie
praktisch sind gemäss eigentlich etwas
anderes leben so das ist die große
forward wogegen moral als gefühlter zwar
sehr zusammen dampft im ruhestand aber
die zeit vernünftig oder irrtums
auffällig also bekannte der rassistische
tendenzen aber wohl tun können zur
höchst vernunft fahren und letztlich das
argument das gefühl hat immer ziemlich
letztlich geht es darum das mitgefühl
aus natürlich konnte ich glaube nicht
dass vermutlich ein allfälliges gefiel
es gibt das buch von fried breithaupt
die dunklen seiten
es
zeigt wie sehr der empathie diskurs
wirklich problematisch ist wer hat
wirklich beim party fähigkeit sehr stark
darauf reagiert dass über keine
dopingsperren hand und importieren sehr
ungleich verteilt werden mir scheint und
man extreme geschickt und mit dem 14 7
li geht so denn die letzte strophe und
becel das finden wo man im asiatische
sensibel wenn sie kommen aus brüssel
können wie sie es plötzlich kostet für
demographie unterschiedlichen größen und
ich glaube schon an diesem tag sind wir
alle sehr froh und sensible menschen
hochsensibilität oft apathisch in
hochachtung vor dem erfahren
kritisiert wird besser
sind hier sehr lieben und wenn dort das
problem freut einen vorteil wir sind
gespannt und wenn das bis zum thema hand
in hand am stammtisch diskutiert über
sensibilität 20
und wenn der neue
deutschland aktivieren